all that stuff we sell in the vending
machines yes oh yeah and they're
breaking good though yeah i know i love
songs sometimes it hits the spot it
really does and being filipino doesn't
help
more mexican yeah
i think we had salt on our candy as a
kid
terrible all right uh what do you think
about outside great today great
great day yeah amazing no complaints no
complaints acs are off windows are open
in your car am i right everybody has
their their windows open as you're
coming into work even in the morning
hours live look outside from our red
rock station casino tower cam if you
look off in the mountains
mainly off mount charleston
you still see snow up there after that
snow that we had earlier this week seven
inches at lee canyon five inches a cal
we will take it 71 are a high for the
day so far we're in the 40s overnight 82
is our average for this time of the year
75 for centennial hills 73 north las
vegas that's not our actual high
remember we probably have another hour
before we actually reach our high and
that will be up to the north of the
national weather service and we'll show
you those numbers in just a bit 73
sunrise mountain
same for whitney ranch 71 for mountains
edge we are typically like you saw in
the low to mid 80s for this time of year
so these numbers have been below average
lately where we were actually in the 60s
i remember that yesterday 67 indian
springs 70 for sandy valley 72 boulder
city 79 for laughlin and get this i'm
going to put this out on social media i
did did this earlier this week so 73
here it's actually warmer look at this
in dc
it's 76 degrees
warmer in d.c than here
in las vegas
the eastern seaboard is loving those
numbers now we got this trough cooler
trough towards the east got some snow in
there too within the four corners region
up there in salt lake the wasatch bitter
roots there too but you'll notice just
how dry and clear we are high pressure
off the coast will start to build in for
the weekend and that will finally bump
the numbers up we'll come very close to
reaching 80 degrees when probably for
sunday right now though we'll still stay
below normal here's your weekend
forecast 73 friday 77 for saturday 79
for sunday
you can almost smell the barbecue
there's a lot of salt on the hamburger
i'm sorry
get these out of here
get it we need to put can we put tofu
put tofu on the grill this weekend all
right
north breezes light winds on saturday
south breezes on sunday
no hamburger for you
here's your temperature trend all right
so we have had eight days including
today of temperatures out of the 80s
last time we had 80s was last thursday
we've been 70s and below normal look at
that 60s yesterday and the previous day
52 overnight it's still going to be
chilly in the morning hours it'll be
clear overnight light winds remember we
should be 60 this time of year tomorrow
our high should be at 82 but we're going
to be 73 tomorrow still staying
unseasonably cool and sunny your 8 day
forecast here you go you're eight on the
eight we'll see those winds kick in the
gear again on sunday monday and tuesday
still no 80s here until we get to
next week thursday and friday 81-83
looking good we'll send it back over you
guys loving it yeah